欸，你聽說了嗎？瑞典有一家做商業軟體的公司叫 Fortnox，他們竟然花了 450 萬歐元，跟一間商學院合作，要研究「到底什麼才能讓公司成功」。
450 萬歐元？而且是「研究成功」？這個數字聽起來有點…出乎意料耶。一般公司砸錢不是都拿去產品開發、市場行銷嗎？這擺明是把錢丟進一個沒什麼直接效益的黑洞啊。
我一開始也覺得有點怪，你說得沒錯，通常研發就是為了新產品。但他們這次是跟斯德哥爾摩經濟學院合作，研究長達十年，要探討的是企業成功的底層邏輯。
十年？這麼長期的計畫，成本划算嗎？而且研究這種抽象問題，效果到底能不能持久，我覺得還有待觀察。萬一研究出來的東西，根本不適用所有公司怎麼辦？
其實原文有提到，Fortnox 的 CEO Tommy Eklund 說，他們想知道的是，從小型髮廊到大型會計師事務所，到底是什麼讓這些企業能為瑞典社會繁榮做出貢獻。
喔，所以他們看的不是單一公司或產品的成功，而是整個產業生態系？這點其實不容易做到。他們自己是做商業軟體的，應該有很多數據吧？
對，Fortnox 本身就是從會計軟體起家，現在是一個雲端平台，服務中小企業和會計事務所。他們每天接觸很多公司的營運數據，所以對「如何衡量成功」這個問題，應該感觸特別深。
嗯，這有點意思。他們是不是發現，現在大家都在追 KPI、追數字，但這些數字其實可能沒有反映公司真正的價值？反而讓管理層只關注容易量化的東西。
你說到重點了。原文有特別指出，當決策過度依賴某些目標時，組織可能反而會優先處理「最容易量化」的事情，而不是真正能創造永續價值的。
所以他們是想開發一套更「負責任」的績效衡量方法？這對創業公司特別有意義，畢竟很多新創公司光看成長率、營收這些數字，很容易就被帶偏。
沒錯。他們這個研究中心的成果會公開，而且 Fortnox 也計畫把研究結果應用到他們自己的產品開發上，幫助客戶設計更好的工具。
這樣看來，這不只是學術研究，還是他們公司提升產品和服務競爭力的一種方式。投資產業知識基礎，反過來回饋自己公司的產品，這邏輯好像說得通了。
對啊。我覺得這點最啟發台灣的中小企業主了。如果我是開一間小咖啡店，除了專注咖啡豆和行銷，是不是也能想想看，整個咖啡產業的成功邏輯是什麼？
怎麼說呢？聽起來有點太大了，一般小店可能很難投入這麼多資源去研究。
我猜啦，也不是要你花幾百萬去研究。但至少可以思考，我們行業裡，那些真正成功的店家，他們除了賣商品，還有哪些是你看不到的「底層邏輯」？可能是員工關係、社區連結，甚至是對供應鏈的影響力。
這倒是。如果能理解這些，也許就能找到新的成長點，而不是一直停留在產品功能迭代。那一般上班族呢？這個概念對我們有什麼用？
其實我覺得，上班族也可以把這個概念帶入自己的工作。很多時候我們都在追求 KPI，追求數字，但有沒有停下來想過，我們現在在做的事情，最終的「成功」是什麼？是為了什麼目標？
意思是，不要只看眼前老闆交代的任務，而是想想這份工作對公司、對客戶，甚至對整個產業的長期價值在哪裡？
嗯，就是這樣。如果能從更宏觀的角度來看自己的工作，或許會更有方向感，也更容易找到創新的空間，而不是困在日常的瑣碎裡。這好像也提醒了我們，有時候跳脫常規思考，反而能找到更深層次的價值。